la france s'inquiète de la situation en
roumanie notre ambassadeur a été rappelé
à paris pour consultation le quai
d'orsay est préoccupée par la situation
des droits de l'homme dans ce pays est à
l'origine de cette inquiétude une lettre
qu'un certain nombre de personnalités
roumaines aurait écrite au président sur
ces secours une lettre dans laquelle les
signataires font part d'une d'un certain
nombre de griefs contre lui et qui est
souvent appelé même dans son pays le
dictateur rouge alors si des signataires
auraient été arrêtées jérôme baugnies
pourquoi faut-il urbanisées les
campagnes si dans les villes on ne peut
pas assurer des conditions normales de
vie cette critique acerbe du régime de
nicolae ceaucescu et signé par six
anciens dirigeants du parti
dans une lettre ouverte adressée au
conte du quator roumains tous les six
viennent d'être placés sous surveillance
étroite de la police par un quasi
réflexe conditionné du pouvoir leur
lettre ouverte dénonce en priorité la
politique mise en oeuvre ces dernières
années pour regrouper les villages et
des racines et des populations dans des
régions de transylvanie où les paysans
sont en majorité d'origine hongroise ou
allemandes suspect donc pour un régime
qui prône la romanisation les
destructions de petits villages tout
comme les gigantesques travaux de
reconstruction du centre de bucarest ont
pour effet de déstabiliser de façon
permanente des populations urbaines ou
rurales qui ont toutes les raisons de se
révolter
le gouvernement roumain expliquent la
pénurie par les efforts déployés pour
rembourser la dette extérieure du pays
notamment en exportant des produits
agricoles c'est ce qui provoque la
colère de simone veil députés centristes
au parlement européen que toute
importation de produits roumain est de
produire 2 notamment de produits
agricoles ne soit plus accepter pour
l'instant car on sait que si le peuple
roumain n'a rien à manger
c'est parce qu'on exporte tous les
produits nous ne pouvons pas manger le
pain des roumains la communauté
européenne vient de suspendre ses
relations commerciales avec la roumaine
hainaut tél